researchers at the University of
Michigan have found out something that
I'm pretty sure I knew all along
processed foods can often be just as
addicting as hard alcohol and drugs the
reason i think i know this is because
anytime i have one Dorito i have that
immediate urge to eat a thousand more
and if i'm on a plane and they give me
just like a little bag of something I
want eight more bags like that's
actually a real thing and I don't think
I'm the only one that that's happening
too we've got a little more info on the
study the authors of the study wanted to
discover what foods were most likely to
lead to food addiction they found that
highly processed foods were more likely
to have the same effect on the brain as
hard drugs compared to non processed
foods like wheat fish and other healthy
foods just like other addicts don't
choose to become addicted to heroin or
cocaine obese people don't choose to be
fat so I think this is really
interesting and it's exactly what I was
just saying poor so let's just start on
that antidotal part do you guys find
that too that there are certain foods
processed foods that you have one I mean
people say that about potato chips all
the time versus if you were having a
bowl of rice let's say yeah I'm chicken
you eat till your satiated and then
you're not suddenly like I need more
chicken and rice yeah I mean that's why
I don't have Nutella at home if I have
like one spoon of nutella that's it i
eat it with a spoon so it's just idling
way it's my that is doing why would you
spread it on bread does yeah what you
just get your whole mouth into the right
right sometimes I just put in a big bowl
but um I I think that this has an
evolutionary advantage but unfortunately
we live in a completely different time
with the advantage no longer exists
right so when we were hunter-gatherers
like we of course want fattier foods
right because we need the fattier foods
to survive but now we fou diz plentiful
you know and so we still want the same
things but there's an abundance of it
and we eat too much of it and then of
course we're not as physically active as
we were ages ago get fat that's the way
it works right and by the way with all
this process stuff there's plenty of
evidence that they literally are putting
in flavors that they make up because
they make our taste buds go nuts so that
you just want more of them right mm-hmm
well I feel that way about sugar I'm not
sure about necessarily like the
processed food thing but there's sugar
learn everything you'd be shocked like
things like that are supposedly like
healthy mothers nature's bounty
smoothies yeah like it's full of sugar
so and I don't love it yeah I mean for
me they specifically target food that
tastes like Latino so I can't taste like
Latino I think we're gonna have a gift
for many more something made on that one
um who do we blame for this like is this
our fault or is this do we blame the
corporations do we blame the government
that told us to eat this stuff do we
blame McDonald's do we blame ourselves
for not being educated enough I don't
know if there's anyone you can blame
other than the companies they're
purposely making their food as addictive
as possible yeah um I know it's really
difficult to control yourself when you
want to eat the fatty food but I think
the best way to combat what's happening
in the country's education right so
passing regulations that ban certain
sizes of sodas or tack certain foods
it's like putting a band-aid on a larger
problem a lot of people don't have
access to healthy food or a lot of
people are simply uneducated educated on
what is and isn't healthy so someone
might see a granola bar and be like yeah
duds granola of course this is going to
be healthy but the reality is Grillo's
like one of the least healthy things
that you can eat and then they wrap it
up in sugar by the way we can't do
something on sugar without me mentioning
my pet peeve number one which is that in
our coke in our coca-cola we don't have
sugar in America oh yea high fructose
corn syrup yeah because corn is cheaper
to make sweet than sugar so you get a
Mexican Coke in America they actually
get sugar in your coke that is
completely bonkers back to the Latino
thing yeah what do you and I'm not sure
we should do you think we're gonna have
rehab for these people soon I mean
eventually really like eventually it's
gonna become looked at like an addiction
right if that's what you see your point
I think in a lot of ways we're as good
as our choices and you know what is
subsidized what is easy easily
accessible what what is you know the
most attractive-looking thing and it's
going to be maybe something that's not
good for you yeah I think we got Anna's
answer to this already but my final
thought on this is what food is your
guilty pleasure but I guess well now is
it some sort of Latino Nutella or
shooter for me I don't
my guilty pleasure is like any type of
chocolate cake that's warm and gooey
with like ice cream so sugar I love
sugar I can confirm that's true because
you brought that time thing to my house
many times Kim I like donuts yes I like
donuts too no I can doughnuts man they
bring us donuts around here on way they
like I can't stop I know I shouldn't and
I can't but actually my healthy
addiction this one's an actual healthy
addiction huh trader joes has these
mesquite almonds and their almonds
almonds are good i think Mesquite's
pretty good i like that i think i'm
doing alright anyway oh my god uh do you
loved Latinos the 11-foot sugar what do
you sort of what I was interested I
don't know where are you going like oh
my god that was odd anyway what get you
off let us know it's right